hi I'm Logan browning I'm Allison
Williams and we're here with BuzzFeed
doing horror would you rather ready yeah
chaser okay oh okay
would you rather eat a plate of maggots
too close to home
or drink a cockroach smoothie to keep
your BFF alive honestly like I'm I'm
such a smoothie girl I'd really am NOT
grossed out by that I feel a cockroach
smoothie in LA and girls would be like
my skin just was never 100% yeah I think
they probably have protein i I'm pretty
sure you put some spinach and some
blueberries in there and it's I'd love
that but I need to say something
it is a cockroach smoothie and you are
still adding spinach you are out of your
damn mind if it is a cockroach smoothie
there's nothing healthy in it other than
but isn't it like a good idea to make it
taste better
just spinach make a smoothie days better
spinach is something I like tolerate in
a smoothie they're like no huge okay
jack - some people like healthier on it
just so funny do like and therein lies
the difference between it would be like
sour patch kids and cockroaches if it
were me yeah yeah would you rather be
forced to live as that's it a demented
doll who haunts children mm-hmm or a
psychotic clown who haunts the elderly
these are both very close to who you are
oh yeah 100% they're a little too close
so I say okay so a doll who haunts
children yeah or a clown who haunted the
elderly I wouldn't rather be either of
those but given the choice like children
are just kind of getting going and the
elderly are often struggling to separate
reality from fiction to begin with so I
feel like if I ageism it is but I just
had again if you have to choose like I
think I would just haunt the elderly and
hope that they would think like either
[ __ ] it
who cares or this isn't real but also
consider the fact that if you haunt the
elderly and they're soon to die they may
come back in height
you well that's just seems fair I'm
actually fine with that deal that's okay
go to that yeah and clown makeup is fun
would you rather be the last one
murdered out of your friend group or be
the only one who survives except for the
fact that Jordan Peele has changed this
but considering the fact that it is
cliche that the black person always dies
first I always would rather be the
surviving person because I feel like
then you can have a sequel I think the
answer were supposed to give is like I'd
rather be like they are more important
than me but obviously we're humans and
our instinct is to survive yeah yeah no
but I really care about my friends I
know I just think that I would want to
live to tell people about them exactly
so yeah definitely I have to live on
yeah yeah I'm the last one what would
you rather be trapped in a house with a
killer and not be able to hear anything
I feel like I saw that movie or trapped
in a house with a killer and not be able
to see anything this seems obvious to me
doesn't really I think I choose to be
able to see is that we were gonna yeah
like I if you can't well we're very our
senses are actually very good in ways
that are surprising like I feel I'm
gonna bleed hear anything
you just feel vibrations etc but I think
a point I think seeing is just like it
would just be easier and a killer in the
house scenario but I think you're right
we underestimate people with different
abilities so I think that yeah it would
be actually pretty cool superheroes
would you laugh rather find an old lady
go stare at you every night as you go to
bed or have the same ghost behind you
every time you look in a mirror easy
that's easy yeah
honestly I'm quite lonely so I wouldn't
mind looking in the mirror and seeing
somebody there it would be a little
comforting especially because over time
they would become my friend it wouldn't
be like a ghost I'd be like hey Johnny
and we would kind of have a root of
wisdom - yeah yeah and we'd have a
rapport and I don't know I think it
would be kind of nice I was gonna say
stare at me as I go to bed and then I
remembered haunting a pill house and I
actually very vehemently changed my mind
cuz that [ __ ] is scary yeah it is lady
that's like on this no no would you
rather have
horrible nightmares for the rest of your
life or always feel like someone's
following you for the rest of your life
I think I'd rather feel like someone was
following me
I can I can overcome that I can just
have someone screw that bull I can have
someone whose job it is to walk back to
back with me and just keep it like we
can be attached at the back with Velcro
or something and their only job in life
can be to tell me that I'm not being
followed but sleep is important yeah and
horrible nightmares like no would you
rather get stabbed in the eyeball or
have all five fingers ripped off of one
hand the visceral emotion I'm receiving
when I'm thinking about what it really
requires to rip one digit off of one's
hand is in tense and I feel like that's
five different things that has to happen
but with my eye it's just so one Queen
one Queen one Queen eyeballs one clean
stabbing and I feel like that just would
be I feel like that would be less
painful then dealing with it five times
yes but long term well long term it's
like I still have my sight if I lose all
five of my digits on one hand then I
only have one hand but I can still see
with my other eyeball oh no Ames you
have two of each but it's otherwise okay
Wallis logic is there a way to win would
you rather like I don't this is is there
a way for both of us to lose I think
that can't get done all right we just
finished playing horror would you rather
that was my first time ever playing
would you rather I wasn't allowed to
play games growing up whoa we're gonna
talk about that later and so much more
check out the perfection on Netflix you
will not regret it it's wild would you
rather watch the perfectional Netflix or
anything else the prevention watch the
perfection on that place ie yeah
[Music]